my life is always a mess and the
situations I'm in are ridiculous always
regardless of where I will find trouble
and it's is that you're your whole life
yes everywhere I go from the minute I
was born I'm just like a trouble magnet
so or not trouble like just
Ridiculousness yeah you know like uh uh
like this summer or when covet happened
I rented this house in Maine and I had
invited a bunch of different friends to
come through for like I rented it for
like a month and my sister my brother
came up and you know like halfway
through the the trip we're like at Kenny
bunk board playing pickleball with
George Bush the George W bush the
president and I'm like I'm high as a
kite I've taken two Edibles my back was
out and I was being wheeled around there
Kenny bunkport thing on this chair that
I had to travel with because I had like
slipped a disc in my back and I am so
picturing a high back wheelchair like a
director's chair but like and being
carried and we're sitting there playing
pickleball and I told Barbara George
Bush's daughter you know I'm like [__]
I call her sister she calls me [__] and
because we've known each other and she
also College yeah and she calls you
[__] also and she said she was like you
have to come over and play you know
pickleball candy book board I was like
[__] no I can't see your father I'm
like I can't do that like I won't be
able to control myself another example
of me not being able to I go I will have
to I I don't want to be rude to someone
in their own house or on their own
compound yeah you know I can't do it and
then of course we get there he's
Charming as anyone could ever be and I'm
just like you guys we have to get out of
here I cannot be seen with this level of
a republican I'm like we have to go in
my family and it was just this and then
he's showing me his artwork and I have
my sunglasses on because I had taken
like a really strong edible and he's
like going up I'm following up the
stairs and he's like look at this
painting look at this painting and I'm
like and he goes can you take your
sunglasses off and I'm like I'm under
the influence of cannabis and I cannot
take them out yeah I had to that's like
10 million cops I know
he knows what's up he's sober so he had
a good time once and then uh I I take
that's what's over means I had a good
time you used to be fun and so then he
takes his glasses off like this and I or
I take my glasses off and like look at
his artwork and I was like I didn't know
what to say I'm a Philistine when it
comes to like you know paintings and
just say breaststrokes but yes and I
said I just looked at the picture and
said wow the paint is so thick
okay and that was like okay I gotta get
the [__] out of here now that is it I
know I mean it was ridiculous I was like
great and then we're driving home my
brothers the famous
brother's like God it goes oh stuff like
this only happens when you're around I'm
like obviously Roy what do you think
you're gonna
Bush's house
but I mean
big high profile example but things like
that are always happening and I'm you
know that's what I write books about and
do my stand up about and everything is
about myself deprecating lifestyle
you're so right I I just said to Val the
other night I was like I forgot that
there's like it's almost essential to
keep some self-deprecation in in your in
your stand-up some I think more than
some yeah I hear you and I just forgot
it was one of the spices it's something
I've been doing it 20 years now and it's
just kind of like it's too much of a
foregone conclusion that you should do
well and it becomes almost like a
monster then you're like wait we got
into this because I wore like
button-down rayon shirts I was always
blushing and I had wet hands you know
what I mean like that's why I I started
it so why are you acting like something
else just because people come and see
you like remember that yeah keep a
tether to it so I guess it's also
different styles of Comedy too not
everybody is self-deprecating you know a
lot of people are observationalists and
then that's about other people's ways
but I yeah I'm very sorry I haven't made
cotton balls man don't need cotton balls
is that an impersonation of who that was
Bill Cosby oh copy sorry I'm in jail now
what's the deal with the bars they're
always horizontal makes me look fat it's
just like Bill Cosby
Jewish like a Jewish what's the deal
with clams almost like a black she
speaks Spanish it's never really
explained it's almost like a black
Seinfeld Theo get in here okay Ordinary
People okay I'm getting it now yeah I'm
good I got it consider it gotten
oh yeah
[Music]